ne vous fiez pas aux apparences les
manuels dardenne qui s'entraînent à
l'escrimé est en fête
écuyer les screen fait partie de sa
formation à l'académie du spectacle
équestre de bartabas un lieu prestigieux
et d'insécurité son ouverture en 2003 un
jour j'ai entendu parler que bartabas
créer une académie à versailles qui
recrutent et que des filles
donc j'ai quand même tenter ma chance
j'étais sélectionnée pour aller à
aubervilliers pour pour passer les
auditions et puis ça s'est bien passé on
peut dire des manuels qu'il est né dans
l'équitation une passion héritée de son
père sortait de la maison je faisais 5
mètres j'avais les écuries donne qu'un
troisième amiens cheval et j'ai grandi à
cheval quoi j'ai jamais connu de poney
toujours des grands chevaux à 11 h
mon premier spectacle la première
représentation en public avec ton copain
emmanuel a effectué son service
militaire à la garde républicaine de
paris et à continuer d'enchaîner les
spectacles avant de rejoindre les
grandes écuries de versailles aux côtés
de bartabas emmanuel est aujourd'hui
écuyer titulaire il côtoie des écuyers
confirmé qu'ils participent au spectacle
de bartabas depuis quelques années il
forme aussi des cavaliers en stage qui
intégreront le spectacle équestre
après un ou deux ans d'apprentissage on
est trois être là depuis le début
il ya plus d'un an avec l'or avec leur
guillaume en a
en et coordinateur artistique et
pédagogique vague lors du spectacle aux
règles on voit pas ça va pas les
transferts de chevaux contre le malade
en prendre un autre
une journée type commence vers 7 heures
chaque écuyer dispose d'environ 4
chevaux ils sont une dizaine en tout à
se répartir 44 bête balade dans le parc
du château détente à la longe
répétitions deux chorégraphies ou
exercice de dressage chaque homme
organise son travail avec ses chevaux
sur la semaine à savoir qu'il ya six
jours
ils connaîtront de repos il ya ces jours
donc deux jours de spectacle samedi
d'image de lune reste quatre jours pour
travailler le cheval en dehors des
spectacles ya plus de ça il faut suivre
les cours à l'académie
on a des cours de kyudo c'est du tir à
l'arc du tir à l'arc japonais avec un
arcady symétrique ajoutez à cela les
cours de chant d'escrimé artistique de
pilates et de danse ne l'oublions pas il
s'agit d'une académie du spectacle
équestre l'enseignement dispensé est
gratuit et chaque écuyer touche un
salaire les éclés par exemple à vienne
en autriche qui gagne 3,8 milles euros
par mois ou à l'année bien loin je
dirais qu'un écrit en france gagne entre
dire et 2000 euros et au mieux 4 me
le gain ne constitue aucune motivation
est régulier c'est avant tout comprendre
et communiquer avec son cheval mais
c'est aussi mettre sa passion au service
de l'art et du spectacle entre les
chorégraphies à deux chevaux à trois
roues ca
les chevaux chorégraphies des scream
avec six chevaux jeunes sans oublier les
solos au trot au galop et des combats
des scream la création de bartabas
intitulé la voie de l'écuyer est à
découvrir tous les samedis et dimanches
au prendre écurie devait resserrer